josiane ouais c'est thierry ardisson ah
ouais alors non seulement ils te font
faire toutes les télés mais en plus et
ils te livre en retard aux télés
importante à quelle peur nous est à
clichy temps je fais écouter le public
un mois dominique lavanant qui sera en
retard bonté intérêts de dépêcher parce
que moi je peux pas les tenir là tu vois
ah bah tu vas manger sur le plateau
josiane as tu veux on peut pas avec des
sushis sur le plateau on va s'en occuper
oui bah je sais mais ils te font faire
toutes les émissions tape pas une minute
entre deux émissions et itil pas à
bouffer et imagine le public est contre
ce calme non bon bah je t'embrasse
dépêche-toi a tout de suite là où on est
sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou